OK. I listen to a lot of podcasts. I host a radio show that is distributed as a podcast. So I had a special interest in some interviews that one of my colleagues, Zoe Chace, did recently. She's one of the reporters for Planet Money, which itself is a podcast.
好的。我听过很多播客。我主持的广播节目也以播客形式发布。所以我对我的同事佐伊·蔡斯最近做的一些采访特别感兴趣。她是《Planet Money》的记者之一，这本身也是一个播客节目。
Zoe was interviewing these two guys, Jim Logan and Richard Baker, who say that their company, Personal Audio, holds the patent on podcasts. And basically, anybody who makes a podcast owes them money. Zoe pointed out to them that their interview was going to be used on a podcast that has not paid them.
佐伊采访了两个人，吉姆·洛根和理查德·贝克，他们声称他们的公司“个人音频”（Personal Audio）拥有播客的专利。基本上，任何制作播客的人都欠他们钱。佐伊向他们指出，他们的采访将会在一个没有向他们付费的播客节目中播出。
So are we doing something illegal right now, though?
那么，我们现在做的这件事违法吗？
I wouldn't comment on that.
我不会对此发表评论。
I wouldn't comment on it.
We don't-- I don't comment on the legalities.
我们不——我不会对法律问题发表评论。
Jim Logan says that he is one of the inventors of podcasting, even though he has never made a podcast himself. Here's how he figures. His company Personal Audio, back at the dawn of the internet age in 1996-- this is before the iPod existed-- it's before most homes were on the internet-- they decided to manufacture an MP3 player that would do all kinds of stuff that nobody seemed to be doing just yet, like downloading sound from the internet. And Jim says they filed for a patent.
吉姆·洛根说他是播客的发明者之一，尽管他自己从未制作过播客。他是这样认为的：他的公司“个人音频”在1996年互联网时代的黎明时期——那是在iPod出现之前，在大多数家庭接入互联网之前——他们决定制造一种MP3播放器，能够执行各种当时似乎还没有人做过的事情，比如从互联网下载音频。吉姆说他们申请了专利。
We didn't use these words back then. But buried within that patent description were ideas such as playlist and podcasting.
我们当时并没有使用这些词汇。但埋藏在那份专利说明书里的，正是播放列表和播客之类的想法。
They tried to design and manufacture their newfangled MP3 player for about a year, he says. And they failed. They gave up.
他说，他们花了大约一年时间设计和制造他们那种新潮的MP3播放器。但他们失败了。他们放弃了。
So they never actually succeeded in making a device that could download audio off the internet and play it. They never made a podcast. Instead, they switched to a different technology-- an earlier technology. They decided to distribute magazine articles on cassette tapes.
所以他们从未真正成功制造出一台能从互联网下载音频并播放的设备。他们从未制作过播客。相反，他们转向了另一种不同的技术——一种更早期的技术。他们决定用盒式磁带分发杂志文章。
--which was kind of a crude form of podcasting, you might say.
——你可能会说，那是播客的一种原始形式。
In this version of the history of podcasting, this right here would be one of the very first podcasts. And there is nothing digital about it at all. This is one of those old cassette tapes. These guys brought a stack of them to the interview.
在播客的历史版本中，这东西可以算作最早的播客之一。而且它完全没有任何数字化成分。这只是那些旧式盒式磁带之一。这几个人带了一摞到采访现场。
Welcome to "Amazing-- the Best of Popular Science," brought to you by Magazines on Tape. Coming up, answers to some questions you have probably wondered about. What happens in your head when you have a headache? How does quicksand work? Why does your car--
欢迎收听《Amazing——科学大众精选》，由“磁带杂志”为您呈现。接下来是您可能一直好奇的一些问题的答案。当你头痛时，你的大脑发生了什么？流沙是如何运作的？为什么你的车——
This business also failed. But the way our patent system works, even though these guys never successfully created a system that took podcasts from the internet and put them into a portable audio player, they patented the idea that such a thing could happen. And now that other people have figured out how to do it, they want to get paid. It's only fair, Jim Logan told Zoe.
这项业务也失败了。但按照我们专利制度的运作方式，尽管这几个人从未成功建立一个系统来从互联网获取播客并放入便携式音频播放器，但他们为这种事情可能发生的想法申请了专利。现在，其他人已经弄清楚了该怎么做，他们就想要钱了。吉姆·洛根告诉佐伊，这是合情合理的。
I put my dollars and my time and my energy on the line. I took the market risk. And I went to market 10 years before people say that podcasting was invented in 2005. We were out there in-- well, not 10 years. We were out there in 1998, probably, with an offering.
我投入了我的金钱、时间和精力。我承担了市场风险。我在人们所说的2005年播客发明之前的10年就进入了市场。我们在——好吧，不是10年。我们大概在1998年就推出了产品。
But I mean, these are cassette tapes. Like, this is not the iPhone.
但我意思是，这些是盒式磁带。这又不是iPhone。
Well, remember, the patent talks to having it very similar to an iPhone-- a computerized device that would do this. What was happening there is they couldn't get the product done.
嗯，记住，专利谈论的是一种非常类似于iPhone的东西——一种能做这些事情的计算机化设备。当时的情况是他们无法完成那个产品。
These guys say that for now, they're not asking nonprofit podcasters, like our program, to pay them licensing fees-- just for-profit podcast businesses, like Adam Carolla and The Stuff You Should Know podcast, which is owned by Discovery Communications, and Marc Maron's comedy podcast, WTF, which Maron produces literally in his garage.
这几个人说，目前他们并不要求非营利性播客（比如我们的节目）向他们支付许可费——只针对营利性播客业务，比如亚当·卡罗拉和《Stuff You Should Know》播客（由探索通信公司所有），以及马克·马龙的喜剧播客《WTF》（马龙真的是在自家车库里制作的）。
There's no way I can afford to fight a court battle. And they know that.
我根本负担不起法律诉讼。他们也知道这一点。
--which means he probably has to pay, though the letter he got doesn't specify a price.
——这意味着他很可能不得不付费，尽管他收到的信函中没有具体说明金额。
Why wouldn't they have a number? Why don't they have a percentage in mind or a number that they think is justified? Why don't they have that? Why aren't they willing to say that?
他们为什么不给出一个数字？为什么他们心里没有一个百分比或一个他们认为合理的数字？为什么他们没有？为什么他们不愿意说出来？
Like, yeah, you all owe us $10. Why are they being cagey about that? Because it's a shakedown.
就像，“没错，你们所有人都欠我们10美元。”他们为什么在这方面遮遮掩掩？因为这是一场敲诈。
We have a price. We just don't want to make it public.
我们有一个价格。我们只是不想公开。
I found Richard Baker of Personal Audio to ask the price myself. He wouldn't tell me, either.
我找到了“个人音频”的理查德·贝克，想亲自问问价格。他也没告诉我。
The reason why I'm asking this is because this podcaster said, if this is a fair price-- if you have a fair claim to make-- why wouldn't you name the price publicly if it's a fair price?
我问这个的原因是，这位播客制作者说，如果这是一个公平的价格——如果你们有正当的索赔要求——为什么在价格公平的情况下你们不公开报价呢？
For one, most of our licensees don't want people to know how much they've paid or how many times they're downloading. If we were to give a public price of what it is-- say we settled with someone, and say they paid us $200,000-- someone could easily do the math and figure out exactly what their downloads are.
首先，我们的大多数被许可方不希望人们知道他们支付了多少钱，也不希望人们知道他们的下载量。如果我们给出一个公开的价格——比如说我们与某人达成和解，假设他们支付了20万美元——别人很容易就能算出来他们的下载量到底是多少。
Can you see why I'm asking this? One of the podcasters said, you are not naming a price because it's a shakedown. It's the secrecy that this podcaster found alarming.
你能明白我为什么要问这个吗？其中一位播客制作者说，你们不报出价格是因为这是一场敲诈。正是这种保密性让这位播客制作者感到担忧。
Honestly, we believe this is a very, very fair price. Our goal is to make sure these podcasters succeed so that everybody makes money.
老实说，我们相信这是一个非常、非常公平的价格。我们的目标是确保这些播客制作者取得成功，这样大家都能赚到钱。
Settlements that Personal Audio has made in the past with Apple Computer and with some cellphone companies are also not public information. And the fact is most patent settlements are not public. And you might think, OK, well, so what? But these patent lawsuits are huge. And they're on the rise.
“个人音频”过去与苹果电脑及一些手机公司达成的和解协议也不是公开信息。事实是，大多数专利和解协议都是不公开的。你可能会想，好吧，那又怎样？但这些专利诉讼规模巨大。而且它们正在增加。
The number of patent lawsuits climbed 50% in one year from 2011 to 2012. Entrepreneurs and engineers say these suits hurt and sometimes destroy young companies. They have an effect on the economy, on what we can and cannot do. But it is very hard to find out exactly what is going on.
专利诉讼的数量在2011年到2012年间一年内攀升了50%。企业家和工程师表示，这些诉讼伤害甚至有时摧毁了年轻的公司。它们对经济、对我们能做什么和不能做什么产生影响。但要查清到底发生了什么非常困难。
A good example-- two years ago, we devoted an episode of our program to the patent system. And we tried to explain what was going on by focusing on the company that some people say is the biggest patent troll out there. A patent troll is a company that uses patents mostly to sue other companies and ask for licensing fees.
一个很好的例子——两年前，我们专门用一期节目来探讨专利制度。我们试图通过聚焦一家被某些人称为最大专利流氓的公司来解释正在发生的事情。专利流氓是指主要利用专利来起诉其他公司并索要许可费的公司。
And in that show, we investigated this one patent that the company was involved with. The inventor whose name was on that patent was Chris Crawford. And we learned all kinds of things in that investigation.
在那期节目中，我们调查了该公司涉及的一项特定专利。专利上的发明人名字是克里斯·克劳福德。在调查中我们了解到了各种各样的情况。
But the world of these lawsuits is so secretive there were basic questions we could not answer, like how much money was involved. What did Chris Crawford think of what was being done with his patent? There were 18 companies being sued for infringement on the patent. What was their opinion? How were they handling it?
但这些诉讼的世界太隐秘了，以至于我们无法回答一些基本问题，比如涉及多少钱。克里斯·克劳福德对自己专利被这样使用有什么看法？有18家公司因侵犯该专利而被起诉。他们的观点是什么？他们是如何处理的？
Well, two years have passed since then. And I am pleased to say that today-- today-- we can bring you a show where we actually answer the questions that usually in these kinds of cases go unanswered. It is a rare look inside this world.
好吧，两年过去了。我很高兴地说，今天——就在今天——我们可以为你带来一期节目，我们实际上回答了那些在这类案件中通常得不到答案的问题。这是一次深入这个世界的罕见视角。
That litigation from two years ago has finished. The silence has been broken. Many, many facts have emerged that, frankly, kind of stunned us.
那场两年前的诉讼已经结束了。沉默已被打破。许多事实已经浮出水面，坦率地说，这让我们感到震惊。
And so today on our show, what we're going to do-- in the first half of the program, we're going to return to that old episode from 2011 explaining the patent and the lawsuit. And then in the second half, we're going to have the answers to many of the mysteries that were still unsolved two years ago.
所以今天在我们的节目中，我们要做的——在节目的前半部分，我们将回顾2011年的那期老节目，解释专利和诉讼。然后下半部分，我们将揭晓两年前仍未解开的许多谜团。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stick around.
来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》，由美国公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。敬请收听。
And with that, I'm going to turn things over to This American Life producer and Planet Money co-host Alex Blumberg and NPR Digital Culture Correspondent Laura Sydell, who report the story.
接下来，我将把节目交给《美国生活》的制作人兼《Planet Money》联合主持人亚历克斯·布隆伯格，以及NPR数字文化记者劳拉·赛德尔，由他们来报道这个故事。
Intellectual Ventures, that firm that people in Silicon Valley point to as a quintessential patent troll, was founded by a guy named Nathan Myhrvold.
高智发明（Intellectual Ventures），那家被硅谷人称为典型专利流氓的公司，是由一个叫内森·麦沃尔德的人创立的。
Nathan Myhrvold used to be the chief technology officer at Microsoft, where he made a lot of money-- hundreds of millions of dollars. Even if you haven't heard of Intellectual Ventures, you might have heard of Nathan Myhrvold.
内森·麦沃尔德曾是微软的首席技术官，在那里他赚了很多钱——数亿美元。即使你没听说过高智发明，你可能也听说过内森·麦沃尔德。
My guest tonight has written a six-volume book on cutting-edge food made with modern science. Please welcome Nathan Myhrvold.
我今晚的嘉宾写了一套六卷本的关于现代科学制作尖端美食的书。请欢迎内森·麦沃尔德。
This is Myhrvold on the television show The Colbert Report, talking about another one of his ventures-- an opus on the science of cooking, which teaches you how to do things like make ice cream with liquid nitrogen. Myhrvold is the kind of guy the press loves to profile.
这是麦沃尔德在电视节目《科尔伯特报告》上，谈论他的另一个项目——一部关于烹饪科学的巨著，教你如何用液氮制作冰淇淋。麦沃尔德是媒体喜欢追踪报道的那种人。
You're a world barbecue champion now?
你现在是世界烧烤冠军了？
Yep.
是的。
You've discovered T. rex fossils. You've studied quantum physics with Stephen Hawking. And you have a new six-volume, 40-pound, $625 book--
你发现了霸王龙化石。你和斯蒂芬·霍金一起研究过量子物理学。你还有一本新的六卷本、40磅重、价值625美元的书——
Yep.
是的。
--called--
——名为——
But this image of Nathan Myhrvold, who gives TED Talks and generally plays the role of an avuncular elder statesman for the tech industry, is at odds with the image of his company, Intellectual Ventures.
但这个内森·麦沃尔德的形象——他做TED演讲，表现得像是科技行业的长者——与他公司“高智发明”的形象不符。
--because Intellectual Ventures has amassed one of the largest patent portfolios in existence. There's an influential blog in Silicon Valley called Techdirt, which regularly refers to Intellectual Ventures as a patent troll. Another blog, IPWatchdog, called Intellectual Ventures "patent troll public enemy number one." And The Wall Street Journal's Law Blog had an article about Intellectual Ventures titled "Innovative Invention Company or Giant Patent Troll?"
——因为高智发明积累了现存最大的专利组合之一。硅谷有一个很有影响力的博客叫Techdirt，经常称高智发明为专利流氓。另一个博客IPWatchdog称高智发明是“专利流氓头号公敌”。《华尔街日报》的法律博客有一篇关于高智发明的文章，标题是“创新的发明公司还是巨型专利流氓？”
I put the question to Nathan Myhrvold.
我把这个问题抛给了内森·麦沃尔德。
Are you a patent troll?
你是专利流氓吗？
[CHUCKLING] Well, that's a term that has been used by people to mean someone they don't like who has patents. I think you would find almost anyone who stands up for their patent rights has been called a patent troll.
[笑] 嗯，这是一个被人们用来指代他们不喜欢但拥有专利的人的词。我想你会发现几乎任何捍卫自己专利权的人都被称为专利流氓。
Intellectual Ventures says Myhrvold is anything but a patent troll. They're on the side of inventors. They pay inventors for patents. They gather these patents together into this huge warehouse of invention that companies can use if they want. Sort of like a department store for patents. Whatever technology you're looking for, Intellectual Ventures has it.
高智发明说麦沃尔德绝不是专利流氓。他们是站在发明家这一边的。他们向发明家支付专利费用。他们将这些专利收集到一个巨大的发明仓库中，供有需要的公司使用。有点像专利百货公司。无论你在寻找什么技术，高智发明都有。
And when reporters come to visit Myhrvold to underline this idea that IV is all about invention, he takes them to see this.
当记者来拜访麦沃尔德以强调IV（高智发明）完全是为了发明时，他带他们参观了这个地方。
[MACHINERY NOISE]
[机器噪音]
GEOFF DEANE: So out here, we're standing [INAUDIBLE] the brink of our machine shop.
杰夫·迪恩：所以在这里，我们站在我们机械车间的边缘。
I'm on a tour with Geoff Deane, who runs the Intellectual Ventures Invention Lab. About 100 people work here. The lab is massive.
我正在与杰夫·迪恩一起参观，他经营着高智发明实验室。大约有100人在这里工作。实验室规模巨大。
There are people walking around in white lab coats mixing chemicals in beakers and looking at stuff under microscopes. There's a machine shop, a nanotechnology section. It's like a playground for scientists and engineers.
到处都有穿着白大褂的人在烧杯里混合化学物质，在显微镜下观察东西。这里有一个机械车间，还有一个纳米技术部门。这就像是科学家和工程师的游乐场。
And if you ask them what they've invented so far, there's a couple things they point to. A nuclear technology, they say, is safer and greener than existing technologies, a cooler that can keep vaccines cold for months without electricity, and the world's most high-tech mosquito zapper, which senses mosquitoes hundreds of feet away by detecting the speed of their wings.
如果你问他们迄今为止发明了什么，他们会指出几件事。比如他们说的一种比现有技术更安全、更环保的核技术；一种可以在没有电力的情况下让疫苗保持冷藏数月的冷却器；还有世界上最高科技的蚊子灭杀器，它通过探测蚊子翅膀的速度在几百英尺外就能感应到蚊子。
But the fact is this lab is a tiny fraction of what the company does. Intellectual Ventures has received a little over 1,000 patents on stuff they've come up with here, which pales in comparison to the more than 30,000 patents they've bought from other people. In fact, nothing that's come out of this lab-- not the mosquito zapper, not the nuclear technology-- nothing has made it into commercial use.
但事实是，这个实验室只是该公司所做工作的极小一部分。高智发明已经获得了1000多项他们在这里开发出来的专利，但这与他们从别人那里购买的3万多项专利相比微不足道。事实上，这个实验室里出来的东西——无论是灭蚊器还是核技术——都没有进入商业用途。
That doesn't matter, executives here say. That's not the biggest part of our business, anyway. The main thing we do is help inventors-- make sure inventors are probably paid for their work.
公司高管们说，这并不重要。无论如何，那不是我们业务中最大的部分。我们所做的主要事情是帮助发明家——确保发明家能因为他们的工作得到合理的报酬。
They say there are inventors out there doing brilliant work, holding patents, but not making money off of those patents. Companies are stealing their ideas. And these inventors don't have the legal savvy or deep pockets to stop them. And that is where Intellectual Ventures steps in to protect the little guy.
他们说，外面有发明家在做极其出色的工作，拥有专利，但没能从这些专利中赚到钱。大公司正在窃取他们的创意。而这些发明家缺乏法律知识或财力来阻止他们。这就是高智发明介入以保护弱势群体的地方。
A lot of people I met at IV told me some version of this story. I heard it over and over. And so finally, I asked for an example. If Intellectual Ventures isn't just a patent troll, give me an example-- someone with a breakthrough who wasn't being paid for it-- who Intellectual Ventures helped out and got paid. Two separate people pointed me to the same guy.
我在IV遇到的很多人都对我说了这个故事的某个版本。我一遍又一遍地听到。最后，我要求提供一个例子。如果高智发明不仅仅是专利流氓，请给我一个例子——某个人有突破性成就却没得到报酬，而高智发明帮了他并让他赚到了钱。两个不同的人都指引我去找同一个人。
JOE CHERNESKY: There's one story I can think of-- a gentleman named Chris Crawford.
乔·切内斯基：有一个故事我可以想到——一位叫克里斯·克劳福德的绅士。
This is one of the people who mentioned Chris Crawford-- Joe Chernesky, a vice president at Intellectual Ventures.
这就是提到克里斯·克劳福德的人之一——乔·切内斯基，高智发明的副总裁。
JOE CHERNESKY: The neat thing about Chris is he had no idea how to get money for his patents. He had this great idea. These patents were immensely valuable because every technology company was adopting the technology.
乔·切内斯基：关于克里斯，妙处在于他根本不知道如何从他的专利中获得资金。他有一个伟大的想法。这些专利非常宝贵，因为每一家技术公司都在采用这项技术。
Yet he didn't know how to get paid. He eventually found Intellectual Ventures. So we bought those patents.
但他不知道如何获取报酬。他最终找到了高智发明。于是我们买下了这些专利。
So I figured, I want to talk to this guy-- not so simple. It turned out trying to talk to Chris Crawford took us on a five-month odyssey where things didn't exactly fit the story that Intellectual Ventures was telling us.
所以我心想，我想和这个人谈谈——没那么简单。事实证明，试图联系克里斯·克劳福德带我们踏上了一段五个月的历程，期间发生的事情并不完全符合高智发明告诉我们的故事。
It started when I called Intellectual Ventures to get Chris Crawford's contact info. I got a strange email back in response. I was told they no longer own Chris Crawford's patent. And I was told he probably wouldn't want to talk to me right now because he was in the middle of litigation.
故事开始于我打电话给高智发明获取克里斯·克劳福德的联系方式。我收到了一封奇怪的回复邮件。我被告知他们不再拥有克里斯·克劳福德的专利。我还被告知他现在可能不想和我谈，因为他正处于诉讼之中。
So we started digging around. We found Chris Crawford in Clearwater, Florida. But as predicted, he never responded to our many emails and phone calls. We were able, though, to locate his patents. There were four of them, all pretty similar. And we focused on one.
所以我们开始四处挖掘。我们在佛罗里达州克利尔沃特找到了克里斯·克劳福德。但正如预料的那样，他从未回复我们的许多邮件和电话。不过，我们确实找到了他的专利。总共有四项，都很相似。我们聚焦于其中一项。
--patent number 5,771,354. He got it in 1998, back in the relatively early days of the internet. And the way IV explained the patent to us, Chris Crawford invented something that we all do all the time now. He figured out a way to upgrade the software on your home computer over the internet. So in other words, when you turn on your computer, and a little box pops up and says, click here to upgrade to the newest version of iTunes, that was Chris Crawford's idea.
——专利号5,771,354。他在1998年获得了该专利，那是在互联网发展的相对早期阶段。按照IV向我们解释这项专利的方式，克里斯·克劳福德发明了一种我们现在一直在做的事情。他想出了一种通过互联网升级家用电脑软件的方法。换句话说，当你打开电脑，弹出一个小方框说“点击此处升级到最新版本的iTunes”时，那就是克里斯·克劳福德的想法。
But when we looked at the patent, it seemed to claim a lot more than that. The patent says this invention makes it possible to connect to an online service provider to do a bunch of stuff-- software purchases, online rentals, data backups, information storage. The patent makes it seem like this one guy, Chris Crawford, invented a lot of what we do on the internet every day. We weren't sure what to make of this. So we turned to an expert.
但当我们看这份专利时，它似乎声称的远不止这些。专利称这项发明使得连接到在线服务提供商来做一系列事情成为可能——软件购买、在线租赁、数据备份、信息存储。专利让人觉得克里斯·克劳福德一个人发明了我们每天在互联网上做的许多事情。我们不知道该怎么看待这一点。于是我们转向了一位专家。
--Laura, is you're going to start by looking at the left and right-hand screen.
——劳拉，你从左边和右边的屏幕看起。
This is David Martin, who runs a company called M-CAM. They're hired by governments, banks, businesses, to assess patent quality, which they do with this fancy software program.
这是大卫·马丁，他经营着一家名为M-CAM的公司。他们受雇于政府、银行、企业，通过复杂的软件程序评估专利质量。
The patent's on the left.
专利在左边。
We asked him to assess Chris Crawford's patent.
我们请他评估克里斯·克劳福德的专利。
Now, if you would please, just click on the patent number itself, Laura. And that--
现在，如果你愿意的话，请点击专利号本身，劳拉。然后那个——
The software program actually scans through millions of patents and analyzes them to see if any of them overlap.
这个软件程序实际上扫描了数百万项专利并对其进行分析，看看它们是否有重叠。
That's a bad number.
那是个糟糕的数字。
An idea being patented is supposed to be non-obvious to a person of ordinary skill in the art. What that means is that you shouldn't be able to get a patent for just a common-sense good idea. It has to be a breakthrough.
一个被申请专利的想法应该是对于该领域的一般技术人员来说是不明显的。这意味着你不应该仅仅因为一个常识性的好点子就能获得专利。它必须是一个突破。
That's correct.
那是正确的。
And what we're seeing on David Martin's computer screen does not look like a breakthrough.
我们在大卫·马丁的电脑屏幕上看到的并不像是一个突破。
5,303 patents that were issued while his was being prosecuted, which covered the same material-- 5,303.
5303项专利，是在他的专利申请过程中发行的，涵盖了相同的内容——5303项。
And so that means that at the same time that Chris Crawford's patent was getting issued--
这意味着，在克里斯·克劳福德的专利获批的同时——
Only 5,303 other people were pursuing the same thing.
有5303个人在追求同样的东西。
And when you say, "the same thing--"
当你说是“同样的东西”时——
I mean the same thing.
我的意思是完全一样。
David Martin may be exaggerating a little here for effect. But as we look through some of the patents that are on the screen, the resemblances are pretty clear. Remember, Chris Crawford's patent is for, quote, "an online backup system."
大卫·马丁可能为了效果稍微夸张了一点。但当我们浏览屏幕上的一些专利时，相似之处显而易见。记住，克里斯·克劳福德的专利是关于“在线备份系统”的。
We asked a second patent expert to evaluate Chris Crawford's patent. And he told us that everything in it was already being done on computers in the 1980s, long before Chris Crawford even filed the patent. He thought the patent never should have been granted in the first place.
我们请了第二位专利专家来评估克里斯·克劳福德的专利。他告诉我们，其中的一切在20世纪80年代的电脑上就已经实现了，远在克里斯·克劳福德申请专利之前。他认为这项专利起初根本就不该被批准。
Patents are so fundamental to the American way of life that they're in the Constitution. Their purpose is, quote, "to promote the useful arts and sciences." If there were no such thing as a patent, Eli Whitney, the inventor of the cotton gin, would have had to keep his invention hidden in a dark room with no windows so nobody would steal the idea.
专利对于美国的生活方式如此基础，以至于它们写进了宪法。其目的是“促进有益的艺术和科学的发展”。如果不存在专利这回事，轧棉机的发明者伊莱·惠特尼就不得不把他的发明隐藏在没有窗户的黑屋子里，以免别人窃取这个想法。
But with a patent, he could publish the blueprints. People would have to pay him if they wanted to manufacture their own cotton gins. And we would have thousands of cotton gins everywhere. Patents make it safe to share and to innovate.
但有了专利，他可以发布蓝图。如果人们想制造自己的轧棉机，就必须付钱给他。然后我们到处都会有成千上万台轧棉机。专利让分享和创新变得安全。
But people in Silicon Valley will tell you the problem with software patents today is that all kinds of things are getting patented that aren't breakthroughs and don't deserve a patent. They're too broad or too obvious. And a lot of the people that tell you that are the people that software patents are supposed to protect-- software engineers.
但硅谷的人会告诉你，如今软件专利的问题在于，各种并非突破性、也不配获得专利的东西都在申请专利。它们太宽泛或太明显了。而很多告诉你这些的人，正是软件专利本应保护的对象——软件工程师。
I have to say I actually worked on a whole bunch of patents in my career over the years. And I have to say that every single patent is nothing but crap.
我必须说，在我职业生涯的这些年里，我确实参与过很多专利的工作。我得说，每一个专利全是垃圾。
This is Stephan Brunner, a programmer. He said something we heard from a lot of software engineers. His software patents don't even make sense to him.
这是斯蒂芬·布鲁纳，一名程序员。他说了一些我们从很多软件工程师那里听到的话。他的软件专利对他自己来说甚至毫无意义。
I can't tell you for the hell of it what they're actually supposed to do. Because I did not-- the company said we have to do a patent on this. And then they send in a lawyer. And you basically say, yeah, that's probably right. That's probably wrong.
我真的说不出它们到底是干什么用的。因为我没有——公司说我们必须在这个项目上申请专利。然后他们派来一位律师。你基本上就说，是的，可能是这样，可能是那样。
And they just write something. And it makes no sense. And personally, when I look at them, I'm not proud at all. Because most of them, again, it's just like mumbo jungo, which nobody understands and which makes no sense from an engineering standpoint whatsoever.
他们就写点什么。这毫无意义。就我个人而言，当我看着它们时，我一点也不感到自豪。因为它们大多数，再说一次，只是没人能听懂的胡言乱语，从工程角度来看完全没有意义。
Stephan Brunner, patent 7,650,296-- quote, "a configurator using structure and rules to provide a user interface." One sample section interests me. The whole thing is like this.
斯蒂芬·布鲁纳，专利号7,650,296——即“使用结构和规则来提供用户界面的配置器”。其中一个样本章节让我很感兴趣。整份文件都是这样的。
"According to one embodiment of the invention, a customizable product class is created. A component product class is added to the customizable product class where the component product class is a subclass of the customizable product."
“根据本发明的一个实施例，创建了一个可定制的产品类。组件产品类被添加到可定制产品类中，其中组件产品类是可定制类的子类。”
The patent system, the way it works now, can actually hinder innovation because patents can be used as weapons against new businesses. Engineers say patents don't help them create new products. Often, they get in the way.
专利制度，按照现在的运作方式，实际上会阻碍创新，因为专利可以被用作对付新企业的武器。工程师说，专利并不能帮助他们创造新产品。它们往往成了绊脚石。
We're at a point in the state of intellectual property where existing patents probably cover every single behavior that's happening on the internet and our mobile phones today.
在知识产权领域，我们已经到了这样一个地步：现有的专利可能涵盖了当今互联网和移动手机上发生的每一个行为。
This is Chris Sacca, a Silicon Valley venture capitalist who's helped lots of companies, including Twitter and Uber, get off the ground.
这是克里斯·萨卡，一位硅谷风险投资家，他帮助过许多公司（包括推特和优步）起步。
So I have no doubt that the average Silicon Valley startup or even medium-sized company-- no matter how truly innovative they are, I have no doubt that aspects of whatever they're doing violate patents that are out there right now. And that's what's fundamentally broken about the system right now.
所以我毫不怀疑，一般的硅谷创业公司，甚至是中型公司——无论它们多么真正创新——我毫不怀疑它们所做的任何事情的各个方面都侵犯了现有的专利。而这正是目前制度从根本上出了问题的地方。
Which brings us back to that patent that Intellectual Ventures pointed us to as an example of the system fundamentally working well-- not being broken-- patent 5,771,354, Chris Crawford's patent. As we've said, this patent seems to cover a remarkable chunk of what's happening on the internet-- upgrading software, buying stuff online, cloud storage, storing data on the internet. If you have a patent on all that, you could sue a lot of people, make a lot of money.
这就把我们带回了高智发明作为制度运作良好（而非崩溃）的例子向我们指出的那项专利——专利5,771,354，克里斯·克劳福德的专利。正如我们所说，这项专利似乎涵盖了当今互联网上发生的大部分显着内容——软件升级、在线购物、云存储、在互联网上存储数据。如果你拥有这一切的专利，你就可以起诉很多人，赚很多钱。
And in fact, that's what's happening with Chris Crawford's patent. Intellectual Ventures sold it to another company, a company called Oasis Research, in June of 2010. Less than a month later, Oasis Research used the patent to sue 16 different tech companies-- companies like Rackspace, GoDaddy, and AT&T-- companies that do cloud storage.
事实上，克里斯·克劳福德的专利现在发生的就是这种情况。高智发明于2010年6月将其卖给了另一家公司，即绿洲研究公司（Oasis Research）。不到一个月后，绿洲研究公司利用该专利起诉了16家不同的科技公司——像Rackspace、GoDaddy和AT&T这样的云存储公司。
You have reached Oasis Research. At the tone, please leave your name--
你已接通绿洲研究公司。请在听到提示音后留下你的姓名——
I called the number on Oasis's website numerous times. But an actual human being never picked up. For a while, the message directed all questions to a lawyer in New York named John Desmarais. He also didn't return our phone calls.
我多次拨打了绿洲网站上的号码。但从没有真人接听。有一段时间，留言指引所有问题联系纽约的一位律师约翰·德马雷。他也没有回我们的电话。
There is hardly any public information about Oasis Research-- minimal corporate filings, no way to know who owned it, how many employees it had, if it even had employees at all. One of the few details that was available-- an address in Marshall, Texas-- 104 East Houston Street, Suite 190.
几乎没有关于绿洲研究公司的公开信息——企业文件极少，无法得知谁拥有它，有多少员工，甚至是否真的有员工。仅有的细节之一是得克萨斯州马歇尔市的一个地址——休斯顿东街104号，190室。
What are you opening the door to?
你在打开什么门？
Right now we're going into the first floor of the Baxter Building, which is 104 East Houston.
现在我们正在进入巴克斯特大楼的一楼，即休斯顿东街104号。
This is Michael Smith. He's an attorney in Marshall, Texas, who does mostly patent cases. He agreed to show us the offices of Oasis Research. They're in a nondescript, two-story building on the town's main square, two doors down from the federal courthouse. He led us into a narrow corridor lined with doors with gold and black office name plates.
这是迈克尔·史密斯。他是得克萨斯州马歇尔市的一名律师，主要处理专利案件。他同意带我们参观绿洲研究公司的办公室。它们位于镇广场上的一栋不起眼的双层建筑里，距离联邦法院有两个门之遥。他把我们带进了一条狭窄的走廊，走廊两侧挂着带有金色和黑色办公室铭牌的门。
And here we go, Suite 190, Oasis Research, LLC.
我们到了，190室，绿洲研究有限公司。
It was late morning on a weekday, not a holiday. But the door was locked. Through the crack underneath, you could see there were no lights on inside.
那是工作日的上午晚些时候，不是节假日。但门锁着。透过下方的缝隙，你可以看到里面没开灯。
Marshall is a very small town-- 24,000 people. Michael was born and raised here. So we started quizzing him about Oasis.
马歇尔是一个很小的城镇——2.4万人口。迈克尔在这里出生长大。所以我们开始盘问他关于绿洲的情况。
Does it have any employees that you know about?
你知道它有什么员工吗？
Not that I know of.
据我所知没有。
Have you ever seen any people coming in and out of that office?
你有没有见过有人进出那个办公室？
No, I haven't.
没有，我没见过。
If you don't mind, I'm going to knock on the door and just see if there's anyone here today.
如果你不介意，我要敲敲门看看今天有没有人在。
[KNOCKING ON DOOR]
[敲门声]
I know this is kind of a cliche at this point-- knocking on the door of the suspected fake office.
我知道到了这一步这有点陈词滥调了——敲响疑似假办公室的门。
Nothing.
没人应。
But we'd flown a long way.
但我们飞了很远的路。
But I will say, standing in that corridor was eerie. All the other doors looked exactly the same-- locked, name plates over the door, no light coming out. It was a corridor of silent, empty offices.
但我得说，站在那个走廊里感觉毛骨悚然。所有其他的门看起来一模一样——锁着，门上挂着铭牌，没有光线透出。那是一条安静、空荡的办公室走廊。
Right next door to Software Rights Archive, Bullet Proof Technology of Texas, Jellyfish Technology of Texas, and a couple others that I recognize as plaintiffs in cases that we're involved in here.
隔壁是软件权利档案、得克萨斯防弹技术、得克萨斯水母技术，还有几个我认出是我们参与的案件中的原告。
Are there are a lot of companies like this here in East Texas?
这里有很多像这样的公司吗？
Yes.
是的。
And we're standing in a whole corridor of them, it seems like.
而且我们似乎站在它们整个走廊里。
Yes. This would be ground zero, yes.
是的。这里可以说是震中，是的。
So what's going on here? It turns out a lot of those companies in that corridor-- maybe every single one of them-- are doing exactly what Oasis Research is doing. They appear to have no employees.
那么这里发生了什么？事实证明，走廊里的许多公司——也许每一家都是——都在做绿洲研究公司正在做的事情。它们似乎没有员工。
They're not making new inventions here. They're filing lawsuits for patent infringement. Patent lawsuits, says Michael Smith, are big business in Marshall, part of the Eastern District of Texas.
它们不是在这里搞新发明。它们是在提起专利侵权诉讼。迈克尔·史密斯说，专利诉讼在马歇尔是大生意，是得克萨斯州东区的一部分。
Smith told us there are about 2,000 patent cases in the courthouse in Marshall. And we got lots of explanations for why-- why all these New York and San Francisco-based companies come to tiny Marshall. One theory-- the juries are friendly to people doing the suing. Another-- medical malpractice attorneys switched careers after Texas passed malpractice tort reform.
史密斯告诉我们，马歇尔的法院里大约有2000起专利案件。我们得到了很多解释，说明为什么——为什么所有这些纽约和旧金山的公司会来到小小的马歇尔。一个理论是——陪审团对起诉者很友好。另一个理论是——医疗事故律师在得克萨斯州通过医疗事故侵权改革后转行了。
My favorite theory, though-- all these patent cases are in Marshall because of the drug war. The flood of drug cases made it impossible for patent suits to get in front of a judge in big cities like Dallas or Houston. So the patent cases moved to sleepy little Marshall.
不过，我最喜欢的理论是——所有这些专利案件都在马歇尔，是因为毒品战争。毒品案件的洪流使得专利诉讼在达拉斯或休斯敦等大城市无法在法官面前审理。所以专利案件就转移到了安静的小马歇尔。
We'd come to Marshall to figure out which story about Intellectual Ventures was true. Are they a patent troll? Or are they out there protecting the rights of struggling inventors everywhere? So we went back to Intellectual Ventures for answers and talked to the company's vice chairman, a guy named Peter Detkin.
我们来到马歇尔是为了搞清楚关于高智发明的故事哪个是真的。他们是专利流氓吗？还是他们在保护各地艰难困苦的发明家的权利？所以我们回到高智发明寻求答案，并与该公司的副董事长彼得·德特金交谈。
One interesting footnote about Peter Detkin-- he's actually the person who coined the phrase "patent troll." This was years ago. He was one of the top lawyers at the computer chip maker Intel.
关于彼得·德特金的一个有趣注脚——他实际上是那个创造“专利流氓”这个词的人。那是几年前的事了。他曾是电脑芯片制造商英特尔的顶级律师之一。
They got sued by a company claiming patent infringement. And Detkin called the lawyer who filed the claim a, quote, "patent extortionist." The lawyer turned around and sued Peter Detkin for libel. So Detkin says he held a contest at Intel to come up with a better name.
他们被一家声称专利侵权的公司起诉了。德特金称起诉的律师为“专利敲诈者”。律师反过来起诉彼得·德特金诽谤。所以德特金说他在英特尔举办了一场竞赛来想出一个更好的名字。
And we got a lot of suggestions. But none really fit. But at the time, my daughter was, I think, four or five. And she liked playing with those little troll dolls. The original one, in fact, is still in my office.
我们收到了很多建议。但没有真正合适的。但在当时，我的女儿大概四五岁。她喜欢玩那些小精灵娃娃。事实上，原始的那一个还在我的办公室里。
And so I turned to her. And I said, oh, well, the story of a troll kind of fits because of the whole Billy Goats Gruff thing. It's someone lying under a bridge they didn't build, demanding payment from anybody who passed. I said, how about a patent troll?
所以我转头问她。我说，哦，好吧，精灵的故事有点贴切，因为那个“比利山羊格拉夫”的故事。有人躺在他们没建的桥下，要求过往的任何人付费。我说，专利流氓怎么样？
Of course, the name stuck. After leaving Intel, Detkin teamed up with Nathan Myhrvold to start Intellectual Ventures, the company that many people call the biggest patent troll out there. Peter Detkin obviously disagrees with this characterization.
当然，这个名字传开了。离开英特尔后，德特金与内森·麦沃尔德联手创立了高智发明，这家被许多人称为最大专利流氓的公司。彼得·德特金显然不同意这种描述。
So anyway, we went to Peter Detkin to ask our questions. But even the most basic question about the story Intellectual Ventures had told us, he couldn't answer. Like, for example, when did they buy Chris Crawford's patent?
总之，我们去找彼得·德特金问我们的问题。但即使是关于高智发明告诉我们的故事中最基本的问题，他也无法回答。比如，他们是什么时候买下克里斯·克劳福德的专利的？
There's a document that's publicly available on the US Patent Office website. It traces a patent's ownership history. In the case of Chris Crawford's patent, though, the ownership history was really hard to understand.
美国专利局网站上有公开文件。它追踪专利的所有权历史。然而，在克里斯·克劳福德专利的情况下，所有权历史真的很难看懂。
The first owner is clear. It's Chris Crawford, who was granted the patent in 1998. And then it's clear that a company named Intellectual Ventures Computing Platforce Assets, LLC-- no one can actually tell us what a platforce is-- bought the patent in July of 2010.
第一任所有者很明确。是克里斯·克劳福德，他在1998年获得了该专利。然后很清楚的是，一家名为“高智发明计算平台资产有限公司”（没人能真正告诉我们平台资产是什么意思）在2010年7月买下了该专利。
But in between those two dates, there are two other owners, a company called Kwon Holdings and another one named Enhanced Software, LLC. And what was odd-- Kwon Holdings, Enhanced Software, and Intellectual Ventures all have the same address.
但在那两个日期之间，还有两个所有者，一家名为Kwon Holdings的公司和另一家名为Enhanced Software, LLC的公司。奇怪的是——Kwon Holdings、Enhanced Software和高智发明都有同一个地址。
We showed this document to Peter Detkin for explanation. But this simple question-- when did you buy the patent-- completely threw him off and led the PR woman, who was in the room with us, to jump in and try to shut down the interview. You'll hear her voice in the background.
我们将这份文件展示给彼得·德特金请求解释。但这个简单的问题——你们是什么时候买下专利的——完全让他不知所措，导致房间里的公关女士插话试图结束采访。你会听到她在背景中的声音。
This is just the patent history of Chris's patent. And honestly, we just don't understand this. So if you could explain what we're looking at here. So he invented it in 1998.
这只是克里斯专利的专利历史。老实说，我们真的不明白这个。所以如果你能解释一下我们在这里看到的东西。所以他在1998年发明了它。
[INAUDIBLE] my reading glasses on. So I'm struggling a little bit here.
[听不清] 戴上我的老花镜。所以我在这里有点吃力。
So it says--
所以它说——
OK, so here--
好吧，所以在这里——
So he invented this first--
所以他先发明了这个——
I don't know that getting into the history of this patent is necessary.
我不认为深入探讨这项专利的历史是必要的。
Well, I know where you're going with this.
嗯，我知道你想问什么。
Well--
嗯——
We don't under--
我们不明白——
What's the question? What are you trying to find out?
问题是什么？你试图找出什么？
We would like-- if you could explain. The story you're telling is that you bought this patent from this inventor, Chris Crawford. And then you sold it a little bit later.
我们想——如果你能解释一下。你们讲述的故事是你们从这位发明家克里斯·克劳福德手中买下了这项专利。然后你们稍后将其卖掉了。
But then if you actually look at the history, it's a very different story. It seems very different. So I'm trying to figure out-- if you could explain it to us. That's what I'm trying--
但如果你真的看历史，那是一个非常不同的故事。看起来非常不同。所以我试图弄清楚——如果你能给我们解释一下。这就是我正在尝试——
I won't be able to tell you by looking at this. I mean, I'm not an expert in-- I don't even know what-- you're on the USPTO website? I haven't looked at this particular website in a while. I don't know how it's organized.
看着这个我没法告诉你。我的意思是，我不是这方面的专家——我甚至不知道什么——你在USPTO网站上？我已经有一阵子没看过这个特定网站了。我不知道它是怎么组织的。
I'm trying to be helpful. But the fact is, I know we bought it from some entity of his. And apparently, we then sold it. And again, I have some vague recollection of us doing that deal.
我尽量提供帮助。但事实是，我知道我们是从他的某个实体那里买的。显然，我们随后将其卖掉了。再说一次，我对我们做那笔交易有模糊的记忆。
But are you telling me that you run a patent company and you were the head counsel for Intel in the patent department. You don't know what the patent office website-- you don't know how to read this?
但你是在告诉我，你经营一家专利公司，而且你在专利部门担任过英特尔的首席法律顾问。你不知道专利局网站——你不知道怎么读这个？
Look, I mean, I could look at this if you want. But I haven't looked at this particular website. And I don't know how it's organized.
听着，我的意思是，如果你愿意，我可以看看这个。但我没看过这个特定的网站。我不知道它是怎么组织的。
And I'm not exactly sure what it is you're trying to get at. So I'm happy to answer questions. But if you're going to cross-examine me on the record about a patent website, I don't think that's quite fair.
而且我不确定你到底想得到什么。我很乐意回答问题。但如果你要在大庭广众之下交叉盘问我关于专利网站的事，我认为这不太公平。
So for example, one question is when was it sold to Intellectual Ventures. Because it's sold a number of times. But it's sold a number of times to different companies with the same address as Intellectual Ventures. Does that mean that it was sold to Intellectual Ventures but not--
所以例如，一个问题是它是什么时候卖给高智发明的。因为它被卖了好多次。但它被卖给好几家地址与高智发明相同的不同公司。这是否意味着它被卖给了高智发明但没有——
It's a little different. And we're not going to talk about this--
有点不同。我们不打算谈论这个——
Yeah, I have no idea. There's no way without knowing the details of this particular deal I could ever possibly answer that question.
是的，我不知道。如果不了解这笔特定交易的细节，我不可能会回答那个问题。
We were honestly surprised at this response. It wasn't like this was a secret document or something. What was the big deal about answering the seemingly simple question?
我们老实说对这个回应感到惊讶。这又不是什么机密文件。回答这个看似简单的问题有什么大不了的呢？
Part of it certainly was that we took him a little bit by surprise. I take him at his word that they do a lot of deals. And he doesn't know the details of every one.
部分原因肯定是我们让他有点措手不及。我接受他的说法，即他们做了很多交易。而他不了解每一笔交易的细节。
But part of it is that Intellectual Ventures does a lot of its patent deals through shell companies-- hundreds of them-- shell companies owned by Intellectual Ventures but registered under different names, where it's very difficult to tell that Intellectual Ventures is the actual owner. So what was their relationship with Oasis and Chris Crawford?
但部分原因是高智发明通过壳公司进行了许多专利交易——成百上千个——这些壳公司由高智发明拥有，但以不同名称注册，在那里很难看出高智发明是实际所有者。那么他们与绿洲公司和克里斯·克劳福德有什么关系呢？
Well, we uncovered a document. It's called a Certification of Interested Parties. The court in Texas required that Oasis list all the entities who have a financial stake in the outcome of the case.
好吧，我们发现了一份文件。它叫“利益相关方证明”。得克萨斯州的法院要求绿洲列出所有在案件结果中有经济利益的实体。
This is a standard form that pretty much all parties in civil cases have to file. Oasis listed the parties that most people list-- the plaintiff, the defendants, the attorneys involved. But it added one other name-- Intellectual Ventures.
这是几乎所有民事案件当事人都必须提交的标准表格。绿洲列出了大多数人会列出的当事人——原告、被告、涉及的律师。但它增加了一个名字——高智发明。
So we went back to Intellectual Ventures one more time to talk to Peter Detkin. We picked up where we left off the last time. When did Intellectual Ventures actually buy Chris Crawford's patent? And this time, he had no hesitation about explaining it.
所以我们再次回到高智发明与彼得·德特金交谈。我们从上次结束的地方继续。高智发明究竟是什么时候买下克里斯·克劳福德的专利的？而这一次，他毫不犹豫地解释了。
This is when we bought it-- October of 2007 from CMC Software to Kwon Holdings. And Kwon is a company that we created to purchase these assets. Then when we actually struck a deal and prepared to sell it, in the name of transparency, we changed it to the Intellectual Ventures Computing Platforce Assets.
这是我们买下它的时间——2007年10月，从CMC Software买到Kwon Holdings。而Kwon是我们为购买这些资产而创建的公司。然后当我们真正达成协议并准备出售它时，为了透明度，我们将名称更改为高智发明计算平台资产。
Please don't ask me what a platforce is. I don't know what it is. And then in August of 2010, we sold it to Oasis research.
请不要问我平台资产是什么。我不知道那是什么。然后在2010年8月，我们把它卖给了绿洲研究公司。
We showed Detkin that court document from the Oasis case listing Intellectual Ventures as an interested party.
我们将绿洲案中将高智发明列为利益相关方的那份法院文件展示给德特金看。
OK. And it does list the Intellectual Ventures Computing Platforce Assets as an interested party. I see that.
好的。它确实把高智发明计算平台资产列为利益相关方。我看到了。
And you don't know why in this instance you're listed?
而你不知道为什么在这种情况下你们被列入？
I believe it's because we likely have a back end arrangement here.
我相信是因为我们在这里很可能有一个后端安排。
What does a back end deal mean?
后端交易是什么意思？
We sell for some amount of money up front. And we get some percentage of the royalty stream down the road that is generated from the monetization of these assets.
我们提前卖掉一部分钱。然后我们在后续获得这些资产货币化所产生的版税流的一定百分比。
So just to spell this out, Peter Detkin is saying it's likely that Intellectual Ventures is taking a cut of whatever money Oasis gets from its lawsuits. Oasis, a company with no operations, no products, and as far as we can tell, no employees, whose only activity seems to be taking a very broad patent from 1998 and using it to sue over a dozen internet companies today.
所以为了说清楚，彼得·德特金是在说，很有可能高智发明正在从绿洲公司因诉讼而获得的任何资金中分一杯羹。绿洲，一家没有运营、没有产品、据我们所知没有员工的公司，其唯一的活动似乎就是拿出一项1998年的非常宽泛的专利，并利用它来起诉今天十几家互联网公司。
And so we asked him, how does it feel making money from an entity which is behaving a lot like the patent trolls that he once condemned?
所以我们问他，从一个表现得很像他曾经谴责的专利流氓的实体那里赚钱，感觉如何？
These are patents we used to hold. We no longer hold. And we ensure that we have no control over the actions of these third parties.
这些是我们过去持有但现在不再持有的专利。我们确保我们不对这些第三方的行为有任何控制权。
They are independent actors. They're not Intellectual Ventures. They may be monetizing in ways that we disagree with. But it's not our call. It's theirs.
他们是独立的参与者。他们不是高智发明。他们可能以我们不同意的方式进行货币化。但这不由我们决定。这是他们的事。
But you're also still getting paid.
但你仍然在拿到钱。
Yeah. I mean, I sort of feel like, yeah, well, but what do you expect? You must have some knowledge that it's highly likely these people are going to go and bring lawsuits, especially since they're companies that only have these largely run by attorneys.
是的。我的意思是，我有点觉得，是的，但你期待什么？你一定知道这些人很有可能去提起诉讼，特别是考虑到他们是完全由律师经营的公司。
Sure. No, I understand. And I'm not just disputing any of that. What I'm trying to say, and I apologize if I'm not being clear, is that we do believe-- we believe in our heart that litigation is a highly inefficient way to do licensing. But let's not lose sight that litigation is just licensing by other means.
当然。不，我明白。我不反对任何这些。我想说的是，如果我不清楚，请原谅，我们相信——我们衷心相信诉讼是一种非常低效的许可方式。但让我们不要忘记诉讼只是其他方式的许可。
In other words, we try to license these patents in a friendly way. But sometimes you have to sue.
换句话说，我们试图以友好的方式许可这些专利。但有时你不得不起诉。
Peter Detkin then repeated the company line that we'd heard from a lot of people at IV-- that the mission of Intellectual Ventures is to help inventors bring great ideas into the world, that lots of inventors, they're like great artists-- brilliant, but not brilliant at business. So their patents languish. IV gets their ideas into the hands of companies who will actually build what they've invented.
彼得·德特金随后重复了我们从IV很多人那里听到的公司口径——高智发明的使命是帮助发明家将伟大的想法带入世界，很多发明家就像伟大的艺术家——有才华，但不善于商业。所以他们的专利闲置了。IV把他们的想法交给那些真正会建造他们所发明东西的公司手中。
Coming up, Chris Crawford speaks, and more secrets of Oasis Research revealed. That's in a minute from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，克里斯·克劳福德将发言，还有更多绿洲研究公司的秘密将被揭开。一分钟后，来自芝加哥WBEZ和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "When Patents Attack, Part Two"-- the sequel-- the squeekquel. Today we return to a story we first reported on two years ago about our patent system-- how it sometimes seems to be discouraging rather than encouraging innovation.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目，“当专利攻击时，第二部分”——续集。今天我们回到我们两年前首次报道的一个关于我们专利制度的故事——它有时看起来是如何阻碍而不是鼓励创新的。
A quick review of where we are so far-- OK, there's this company called Intellectual Ventures. Its executives told our reporters that if they wanted to understand what the company was all about-- if they wanted proof that their company is not a patent troll but out there helping the little guy inventor just get fair payment, then they should talk to this inventor that Intellectual Ventures helped out, a patent holder named Chris Crawford.
简单回顾一下我们目前为止的进展——好吧，有这么一家公司叫高智发明。它的高管告诉我们的记者，如果他们想了解这家公司到底是怎么回事——如果他们想要证明他们的公司不是专利流氓，而是为了帮助小型发明家获得公平报酬而存在，那么他们应该去采访一位高智发明帮助过的发明家，即持有专利的克里斯·克劳福德。
But when our reporters tried, Chris Crawford would not talk to them. His patents were now in the hands of a company called Oasis Research. And they were being used to sue over a dozen different tech businesses.
但当我们的记者尝试时，克里斯·克劳福德拒绝与他们交谈。他的专利现在落入了一家名为绿洲研究公司的手中。它们被用来起诉十几家不同的科技企业。
And back in 2011, we didn't learn much more than that. We didn't know who was behind Oasis Research. We had no idea how much money was at stake in the case. We suspected that some companies had settled with Oasis. But we had no idea how many or for how much.
早在2011年，我们就没了解到更多情况。我们不知道谁是绿洲研究公司的幕后主使。我们完全不知道案子涉及多少钱。我们怀疑一些公司已经与绿洲达成了和解。但我们不知道多少家，也不知道金额。
And most significantly, we had no idea how the guy at the center of the whole mystery, Chris Crawford, felt about it all. We had no idea if he knew what was being done with this patent-- if he approved, or if he was like some of the software engineers we talked to who didn't like that their patents got sold to companies that only used them to threaten lawsuits. Well, I'm please to say now we have answers to all of those questions-- every one of those questions. Here again is Alex Blumberg and Laura Sydell.
最重要的是，我们完全不知道整个谜团中心的那个人——克里斯·克劳福德——对此感觉如何。我们不知道他是否知道他的专利被拿来做了什么——他是否批准，或者他是否像我们采访过的一些不喜欢专利被卖给只用来威胁诉讼的公司的软件工程师那样。嗯，我很高兴地说，现在我们有了所有这些问题的答案——每一个问题的答案。这里又是亚历克斯·布隆伯格和劳拉·赛德尔。
There ended up being 18 defendants in the Oasis case-- 18 tech companies it claimed were infringing on Chris Crawford's patents. Many of those 18 companies in the beginning pooled legal forces to figure out what to do.
绿洲案中最终有18名被告——18家科技公司，它声称这些公司侵犯了克里斯·克劳福德的专利。那18家公司中的许多在初期汇集了法律力量来决定该怎么做。
But that pool got smaller and smaller as companies decided to just cut a deal with Oasis-- pay them a licensing fee in exchange for being dropped from the suit. At a certain point, an online backup company called Carbonite was one of two companies remaining in the case. In full disclosure here, Carbonite is an underwriter of National Public Radio news programs. Carbonite CEO David Friend says it was tough to be one of the last men standing, especially with the advice that they were getting from the lawyers they'd hired.
但随着公司决定只与绿洲达成协议——支付许可费以换取被撤诉——这个阵营越来越小。在某个点上，一家名为Carbonite的在线备份公司是该案中仅存的两家公司之一。在此披露一下，Carbonite是美国国家公共电台新闻节目的赞助商。Carbonite首席执行官大卫·弗兰德说，作为最后留下的人之一，处境非常艰难，特别是考虑到他们从聘请的律师那里得到的建议。
You know, what our lawyers were saying is it's going to cost us millions of dollars more to take this to trial. And if we lose, we're really screwed. If we could settle this thing and just have it go away, why don't we do that? And I was sort of like, well, because we're not in violation of their patents. Why should we pay them anything, even a nickel?
你知道，我们的律师所说的是，如果我们要进行庭审，还要花费数百万美元。如果我们输了，我们就真的死定了。如果我们能解决这件事并让它消失，为什么不这样做呢？而我有点觉得，好吧，因为我们没有侵犯他们的专利。我们为什么要付给他们任何东西，甚至一毛钱？
Friend says he'd done a patent search when he started his company and never came across Chris Crawford's patents.
弗兰德说，他在创办公司时做过专利搜索，从未遇到过克里斯·克劳福德的专利。
I mean, the reason was that they were way too old. And we figured, how could there be a patent relevant to backing up over the internet before the internet was even invented?
我的意思是，原因是它们太老了。我们心想，在互联网还没发明之前，怎么可能存在与互联网备份相关的专利？
What they hadn't counted on was a patent that was so broad, it covered anyone backing up any data over the internet using any system at all.
他们没料到的是，有一项专利如此宽泛，以至于涵盖了任何使用任何系统在互联网上备份任何数据的人。
As a businessman, you know, I'm put in this situation where my board is saying, you should settle. And my lawyers are saying, you should settle. And everybody else is settling. I felt like we were being extorted.
作为一名商人，你知道，我被置于这样一种境地：我的董事会说，你应该和解。我的律师说，你应该和解。其他人都在和解。我觉得自己正在被敲诈。
The problem is, defending a patent case is really hard. Patents are complicated. So is technology. Trying to explain which part of a patent should or should not apply to which part of a computer program-- it's a trick just to get the jury to understand, let alone go along with your point of view.
问题是，为专利案件辩护真的很困难。专利很复杂。技术也是如此。试图解释专利的哪一部分应该或不应该适用于计算机程序的哪一部分——光是让陪审团理解就已经是个把戏了，更不用说让他们同意你的观点了。
But there is an easier way to win a patent case, a way where you don't have to force a jury to second guess the experts at the patent office. If you can demonstrate that the inventor wasn't telling the truth when he filled out the application-- if, for example, he wasn't the only inventor. So lawyers for Carbonite and the other company that had chosen not to settle-- EMC-- started to dig into Chris Crawford's history, looking for clues that might invalidate his patent.
但有一种赢得专利案件的简单方法，一种你不需要强迫陪审团去质疑专利局专家的方法。如果你能证明发明人在填写申请时没有说实话——例如，他不是唯一的发明人。所以Carbonite和其他选择不和解的公司——EMC——的律师开始挖掘克里斯·克劳福德的历史，寻找可能使他的专利无效的线索。
Carbonite's Chief Counsel Danielle Sheer says one of the first places they went looking was the company where Chris Crawford was working at the time he claimed to have come up with his idea.
Carbonite的首席法律顾问丹妮尔·希尔说，他们寻找的第一个地方之一就是克里斯·克劳福德在声称想到这个主意时工作的公司。
We located some individuals who had worked with Chris Crawford in the early 1990s. And I'll call him the person who connected all the dots-- was this man named Chuck Campos, who was Chris Crawford's boss in 1991 for a company called ACS.
我们定位了一些在20世纪90年代初与克里斯·克劳福德一起工作的人。我会称他为连接所有点的人——就是这个叫查克·坎波斯的人，他在1991年是一家叫ACS的公司里克里斯·克劳福德的老板。
Lawyers described Chris Crawford's patents to Chuck Campos and asked if he knew anything about the circumstances where he developed those ideas. And he told them, yes. I was with him when those ideas were developed. And they weren't only Chris Crawford's ideas.
律师向查克·坎波斯描述了克里斯·克劳福德的专利，并询问他是否知道他开发这些想法的情况。他告诉他们，是的。当这些想法被开发出来时，我与他在一起。而且那不只是克里斯·克劳福德一个人的想法。
Chuck Campos told the lawyers that the ideas mainly came from two other guys, Jack Byrd and Don Atwood.
查克·坎波斯告诉律师，这些想法主要来自另外两个人，杰克·伯德和唐·阿特伍德。
This was in 1990. Don Atwood and Jack Byrd are business partners. They have a company called WBT, LLC. Jack Byrd loved acronyms. WBT stands for We've Been There.
这是1990年。唐·阿特伍德和杰克·伯德是商业伙伴。他们有一家叫WBT的公司。杰克·伯德喜欢首字母缩写。WBT代表“We’ve Been There”（我们去过那里）。
And the two of them were working on a technology consulting company. And they lived about 30 miles apart. And I think they were developing software.
他们两人当时在经营一家技术咨询公司。他们住的地方相距大约30英里。我想他们当时正在开发软件。
Two idea guys had a lot of technical experience. And they wanted to save their work. And at the time, the only way to do that was to download it to floppy disk drives.
这两个点子多的人有丰富的技术经验。他们想保存他们的工作成果。在当时，唯一的办法就是下载到软盘驱动器上。
But then, the disk drives are just sitting at your house, so not safe from a fire or some other natural disaster.
但随后，驱动器只是放在你家里，所以无法抵御火灾或其他自然灾害。
So they decided, well, we need to keep this data safe. So let's download a copy of what we're working on on floppy disk drives. And I'll meet you halfway in between our homes-- 15 miles each. And let's exchange the floppy disk drives. That way, we've got a little bit of disaster recovery contingency.
所以他们决定，好吧，我们需要保护这些数据。所以让我们把我们正在做的工作拷贝一份到软盘上。我会在我们家中间见你——各走15英里。然后交换软盘。那样的话，我们就有了灾难恢复的应急方案。
Yeah. You put your data on my computer. And I'll put my data on your computer. And then they'll both be relatively safe.
是的。你把你的数据放在我的电脑上。我把我的数据放在你的电脑上。然后它们就都相对安全了。
That was their backup system-- driving 15 miles each way, meeting in the middle, getting out of their cars, and exchanging a pair of floppy disks.
那就是他们的备份系统——开车各走15英里，在中间碰面，下车，交换一对软盘。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
Naturally, being idea guys, they thought, there has to be a better way. Phone modems were just becoming ubiquitous around this time. And they thought, how about a business backing up data remotely over the phone line using a modem?
当然，作为有点子的人，他们想，一定有更好的办法。电话调制解调器当时刚刚开始普及。他们想，通过电话线使用调制解调器远程备份数据作为一项业务怎么样？
A little bit later, Jack Byrd meets Chuck Campos, tells him about the idea. And he joins the group. They decide they need a specific type of computer to back up all the data-- something called an AS/400.
不久之后，杰克·伯德遇见查克·坎波斯，告诉他这个想法。然后他加入了这个小组。他们决定需要一种特定类型的电脑来备份所有数据——一种叫做AS/400的东西。
That is finally where Chris Crawford comes into the situation. Chris Crawford was hired by Chuck Campos at ACS. He had expertise with the AS/400.
这终于就是克里斯·克劳福德进入情况的地方了。克里斯·克劳福德是被查克·坎波斯在ACS雇佣的。他具备AS/400方面的专业知识。
He was a junior guy at this point. And Chuck asks him if he wants to be part of their group. Because they want to get an online backup business going.
他当时是个新人。查克问他是否想加入他们的小组。因为他们想启动在线备份业务。
The group met regularly Saturdays at Jack Byrd's apartment over the course of a couple months. And during these meetings, they discussed all sorts of things, from the technical details of how this backup system would work to details about the company itself-- how they'd split ownership four ways-- 25% each. And also what the new company they were forming way back in the early '90s would be called. The name they chose-- PC Oasis.
小组在杰克·伯德的公寓里每周六定期开会，持续了几个月。在这些会议期间，他们讨论了各种各样的事情，从这个备份系统如何运作的技术细节到公司本身的细节——如何把所有权分成四份——每人25%。还有他们早在90年代初组建的新公司叫什么名字。他们选择的名字——PC Oasis。
That's right. The name of the company that Chris Crawford was invited to join in the early 1990s had the same name as the shell company in East Texas that was suing people two decades later.
没错。克里斯·克劳福德在90年代初受邀加入的公司的名字，和两十年后在得克萨斯州东部起诉人的那家壳公司的名字是一样的。
And apparently, the name had also been Jack Byrd's idea. Remember, he was the acronym guy.
显然，这个名字也是杰克·伯德想出来的。记住，他是那个缩写狂人。
It stands for Offsite Automatic-- I don't know. [CHUCKLING]
它代表离线自动——我不知道。[笑]
For the record, Offsite Archival Software and Information Server-- Oasis.
作为记录，离线存档软件和信息服务器——Oasis。
They had actually sketched a sort of a logo-- an idea for a logo for their company.
他们实际上草拟了一个标志——一个为公司设计的标志创意。
Oh, right.
哦，对。
I think it was in Jack Byrd's hand. It was done on pencil and paper. And it was kind of a world-- a globe-- with four palm trees.
我想是杰克·伯德的手笔。那是用铅笔和纸画的。那是一个世界——一个地球——上面有四棵棕榈树。
It was an island.
那是一个岛。
--an island-- that's right.
——一个岛——没错。
--an oasis island.
——一个绿洲岛。
--with four palm trees growing on it, representing the four partners in this business.
——上面长着四棵棕榈树，代表了这家企业的四个合伙人。
So how did this same name come to be given two decades later to a shell company in East Texas? Well, back in the '90s, the first Oasis never got off the ground. The problem was they couldn't figure out a way to get consumer online backup working using the technology that most people had available in their homes in the early '90s-- phone lines and modems. So they disbanded the company and went on their way.
那么这个同样的名字两十年后是怎么被给予得克萨斯州东部的一家壳公司的呢？嗯，早在90年代，第一个Oasis从没搞起来。问题是他们无法想出一种方法，使用大多数人家里当时能够使用的技术——电话线和调制解调器——来实现消费者在线备份。所以他们解散了公司，各奔东西。
But all those meetings where they'd been sketching everything out, figuring out the technology, solving the problems-- Chris Crawford had been the main note-taker at those meetings.
但那些他们草绘所有内容、解决技术问题、攻克难题的会议——克里斯·克劳福德一直是那些会议的主要记录员。
A couple years later, Chris Crawford-- he ends up filing some patents. And he uses the documents that he's created in these meetings to prove that he has this idea and here's how the idea works and to draw the figures for the patent and to come up with the claims. So Jack Byrd, Don Atwood, and Chuck Campos know nothing about what Chris Crawford is doing-- nothing at all.
几年后，克里斯·克劳福德——他最终申请了一些专利。他利用他在会议中创建的文件来证明他有这个想法，以及这个想法是如何运作的，并为专利绘制图表，并提出权利要求。所以杰克·伯德、唐·阿特伍德和查克·坎波斯对克里斯·克劳福德正在做的事情一无所知——完全不知道。
He doesn't start a business. Instead, he sells those patents to a company named Kwon Holdings. It has some kind of affiliation with Intellectual Ventures. And he sells them for millions of dollars.
他没有创业。相反，他把这些专利卖给了一家叫Kwon Holdings的公司。它与高智发明有某种关联。他以数百万美元的价格卖掉了它们。
Do you know exactly how much he sold them for?
你知道他卖了多少钱吗？
$12 million and an ongoing percentage of royalties for anything that the next owner collects.
1200万美元，外加下一任所有者收取任何费用的一定百分比的持续版税。
Wow.
哇。
Do you know what the percentage was?
你知道那个百分比是多少吗？
I think it's something as high as 18 and 1/2%.
我想高达18.5%。
The problem was Chris Crawford had sold something for $12 million that wasn't his to sell. If Chris Crawford's three former business partners had also developed the idea, they should have at the very least been listed as co-inventors on Crawford's original patent applications.
问题是，克里斯·克劳福德以1200万美元卖掉的东西，并不是他一个人拥有的。如果克里斯·克劳福德的三位前商业伙伴也开发了这个想法，他们至少应该作为共同发明人列在克劳福德的原始专利申请上。
So the lawyers for EMC and Carbonite now had something like a smoking gun to use at trial-- these three men with a very compelling story about how the patent had been mostly their idea, not Chris Crawford's. But at trial, it would still be just their word against Crawford's. The lawyers wanted proof-- something in the documents that Crawford filed with the patent office that mentioned the other inventors.
所以EMC和Carbonite的律师现在有一些类似确凿证据的东西可以在庭审中使用——这三个人讲述了一个非常引人入胜的故事，关于这项专利主要是他们的想法，而不是克里斯·克劳福德的。但在庭审中，那仍然只是他们的一面之词对阵克劳福德的说法。律师想要证据——在他提交给专利局的文件中，有提到其他发明人的东西。
There were lots of these documents from those Saturday meetings that mentioned the three partners. Chuck Campos had a box in his attic full of them. But none of those documents mentioning the others made their way into Chris Crawford's patent application. Well, almost none.
从那些周六会议中提到那三位合伙人的文件有很多。查克·坎波斯阁楼里的箱子里装满了这些文件。但没有一份提到其他人的文件进入了克里斯·克劳福德的专利申请。好吧，几乎没有。
In the thousands of pages that Chris Crawford submitted to the patent office in order to obtain his patents, one of the documents had a sentence that said that this is in response to Jack Byrd's idea to provide online backup. And of course, one of the excellent attorneys that worked on this for EMC and Carbonite located that document and questioned Chris about it.
在克里斯·克劳福德为获得专利而提交给专利局的数千页文件中，其中一份文件有一句话说，这是对杰克·伯德提供在线备份想法的回应。当然，为EMC和Carbonite处理此事的优秀律师之一找到了那份文件，并就此质询了克里斯。
The May 23, 1992, proposal, which is marked as Exhibit 10.
1992年5月23日的提案，被标记为证据10。
Yes. I'm looking at it.
是的。我正在看。
And here he is, the man we've been looking for, Chris Crawford, the man who was granted patent number 5,771,354, one of the patents used to sue 18 companies. This is sound from a videotaped deposition he gave as part of the Oasis trial. He's polished-- crisp white shirt, paisley tie, tortoise-shell reading glasses. He's got sandy brown hair, a tan. The lawyer continues to question him.
这就是我们一直在寻找的人，克里斯·克劳福德，获得专利号5,771,354的人，这是被用来起诉18家公司的专利之一。这是他作为绿洲案一部分提供的录像证词中的声音。他很干练——挺括的白衬衫，佩斯利领带，玳瑁框老花镜。他有沙棕色的头发，晒黑的皮肤。律师继续问他。
So the first paragraph of this document reads, quote, "This proposal, it is in response to Jack Byrd's idea to provide automated offsite backup services for PC users." And aren't you in the second sentence saying that Jack Byrd had an idea to provide automated offsite backup services for PC users?
那么这份文件的第一段写着，“该提案，是为了回应杰克·伯德提供个人电脑用户自动离线备份服务的想法。”你在第二句中不是在说杰克·伯德有一个提供个人电脑用户自动离线备份服务的想法吗？
No. What I'm saying is that Jack Byrd had an idea of me pursuing the automated offsite backup services that I had--
没有。我所说的是杰克·伯德有一个让我去追求我已经有的自动离线备份服务的想法——
Chris Crawford then launches into a rather surprising explanation for how the sentencing that this business was, quote, "Jack Byrd's idea," doesn't actually mean that the business was Jack Byrd's idea. His explanation? He was using the apostrophe S incorrectly.
克里斯·克劳福德随后开始了一个令人惊讶的解释，说明为什么那句说这个业务是“杰克·伯德的想法”实际上并不意味着这个业务是杰克·伯德的想法。他的解释？他错误地使用了撇号S。
As far as the apostrophe S-- and I'm still not clear if you're trying to derive a specific meaning with respect to the apostrophe S--
至于撇号S——我仍然不清楚你是否想根据撇号S衍生出特定的含义——
Of course, what would a sentence reading, "in response to Jack Byrds idea" even mean if the S was plural?
当然，如果S是复数，写着“in response to Jack Byrds idea”（回应杰克·伯德的想法）的句子又意味着什么呢？
I'm asking you, though-- you certainly know what the use of an apostrophe S means, do you not?
但我是在问你——你当然知道撇号S的使用意味着什么，不是吗？
[SNIFFING] As I've written documents over the years, there are times when I use an apostrophe S, and it seems like I'm supposed to use an apostrophe S. But I have to say that my grammar is not strong enough to tell you right now with clarity when an apostrophe S is used.
[吸鼻子] 多年来我写过文件，有时我用撇号S，看起来就像是我应该用撇号S。但我必须说，我的语法水平还没到能清楚地告诉你什么时候该用撇号S。
This explanation, apparently, did not convince the jury, and Oasis lost the case. The jury concluded that the patents were indeed invalid for failing to name the correct co-inventors. Yet this victory just shows how difficult it is to defend yourself against a patent infringement claim. The lawyers for Carbonite believe that without that one document-- that one apostrophe S-- they might have lost.
这个解释显然没能说服陪审团，绿洲案败诉了。陪审团得出结论，由于未能列出正确的共同发明人，这些专利确实无效。然而，这次胜利恰恰显示了为专利侵权索赔辩护是多么困难。Carbonite的律师认为，没有那一份文件——那个撇号S——他们可能已经输了。
Because here's how tough the jury was. The jury verdict said that the patents were improperly filed because Jack Byrd's name should have been listed as a co-inventor. Just Jack Byrd-- not Chuck Campos and Don Atwood, the other men who testified under oath that they too had been involved in developing the ideas. Only Jack Byrd's name had been on that document. And only Jack Byrd got credit from the jury as a co-inventor.
因为陪审团的认定过程是这样的。陪审团裁定这些专利提交不当，因为杰克·伯德的名字应该作为共同发明人列出。只是杰克·伯德——不是查克·坎波斯和唐·阿特伍德，那另外两位宣誓作证说他们也参与了想法开发的人。只有杰克·伯德的名字出现在那份文件上。而且只有杰克·伯德得到了陪审团作为共同发明人的认可。
And for the 16 companies that did settle, the verdict may not change anything. In most cases, these licensing agreements have language that makes them nearly impossible to get out of, no matter what happens with the patent later on. This week, we heard back from a spokesman from one of the companies that chose to settle.
对于那16家达成和解的公司来说，判决可能什么都改变不了。在大多数情况下，这些许可协议都有条款使得它们几乎不可能摆脱，无论后来专利发生什么。本周，我们收到了其中一家选择和解的公司发言人的回复。
The spokesman wrote in an email, quote, "We were hit hard by this lawsuit. Infringement on our part seemed completely bogus, but we could not afford to fight it. Even with the settlement, we were forced to lay off employees. We are still--" and "still" is in all caps-- "still paying out on the settlement agreement. We were unaware that the patent had been invalidated. We will be contacting our attorney to see what recourse we may have."
发言人在一封邮件中写道，“我们被这场诉讼重创了。我们就我们的部分进行侵权看起来完全是假的，但我们负担不起起诉它。即使和解了，我们也被迫裁员。我们仍然——”且“仍然”用大写字母表示——“仍然在支付和解协议。我们当时不知道该专利已失效。我们将联系我们的律师，看看我们还有什么追索权。”
Like we've been saying, because so many of these cases settle with nondisclosure agreements, we almost never find out how much money changed hands.
正如我们所说，因为这么多案件都是通过保密协议和解的，我们几乎永远无法发现有多少钱易手。
But because of the Oasis case, we now have a sense of how much money that can be. Because Carbonite won their case and didn't settle, they weren't bound by a nondisclosure agreement. And they were happy to reveal how much money Oasis wanted from them.
但因为绿洲案，我们现在对那个金额有了一个概念。因为Carbonite赢了官司且没有和解，他们不受保密协议约束。他们很乐意透露绿洲想要他们多少钱。
Well, the original number that was thrown out-- I don't think it was official-- was they wanted $20 million.
嗯，最初抛出的那个数字——我不认为它是官方的——是他们想要2000万美元。
Plus a share of our revenues--
外加我们收入的分成——
--going forward.
——向前推进。
--ongoing.
——持续进行。
What?
什么？
[CHUCKLING]
[笑]
Which what David was at was at a little under half of the cash we had in the bank at that time.
大卫当时所处的情况是不到我们当时银行现金的一半。
Plus a percentage of our ongoing business forever.
外加我们持续业务的百分比，永远。
And remember, Carbonite was one of the smaller companies being sued. We don't know what they were asking from the other guys. But a lawyer named Tom Ewing says you can make an educated guess.
记住，Carbonite是被起诉的较小公司之一。我们不知道他们从其他人那里要求多少。但一位叫汤姆·尤因的律师说你可以做一个受过教育的猜测。
Ewing runs a small side business tracking and identifying Intellectual Ventures' shell companies. And he says, assuming Oasis was asking for settlements in rough proportion to the size of the company being targeted, you can put together a pretty good estimate of their total take from this lawsuit.
尤因经营一家追踪和识别高智发明壳公司的小型副业。他说，假设绿洲要求的和解金额大致与被针对的公司规模成比例，你可以对他们从这场诉讼中的总收益得出一个相当不错的估计。
I'm guessing it would be in excess of $100 million.
我猜会在1亿美元以上。
$100 million. And who would have gotten that $100 million? Some of the money went to the lawyers who prepped the case and negotiated the settlements for Oasis. Some of it went to the owner of Oasis Research, a mysterious figure named Gordon Jumonville, who showed up in court every day but never testified and never returned our phone calls. But most of the profit went to Intellectual Ventures.
1亿美元。谁会得到那1亿美元？部分钱给了那些为绿洲准备案件并协商和解的律师。部分给了绿洲研究公司的所有者，一个叫戈登·朱蒙维尔的神秘人物，他每天都出现在法庭上但从未作证，也从未回过我们的电话。但大部分利润都流向了高智发明。
Remember Peter Detkin? When we spoke with him, he explained the financial arrangement with Oasis this way.
记住彼得·德特金吗？当我们与他交谈时，他这样解释与绿洲的财务安排。
We get some percentage of the royalty stream down the road that is generated from the monetization of these assets.
我们在后续获得这些资产货币化所产生的版税流的一定百分比。
And because of documents filed with the court, we now know what the percentage was-- 90. Intellectual Ventures sold Chris Crawford's patents to Oasis Research on the condition that it get 90% of the net profit. That's 90% of tens of millions of dollars.
而且由于提交给法院的文件，我们现在知道了那个百分比是多少——90。高智发明以获得90%净利润为条件将克里斯·克劳福德的专利卖给了绿洲研究公司。那是数千万美元的90%。
Chris Crawford didn't make out too badly, either. Documents also say that Chris Crawford gets 17 and 1/2% of the money that Intellectual Ventures makes. Now, let's just pause to consider that $100 million for a second. That's $100 million off of one guy's patents. That is a lot of money.
克里斯·克劳福德也赚得不差。文件还说，克里斯·克劳福德获得了高智发明赚到的钱的17.5%。现在，让我们停下来考虑一下那个1亿美元。那是一个人专利的1亿美元。那可是一大笔钱。
And other people see that money. And they want in on that action. They think that's a good business-- getting a hold of patents-- using them to sue people.
其他人看到了那笔钱。他们也想参与其中。他们认为那是一项好生意——控制专利——利用它们起诉人。
Tom Ewing, the lawyer who tracks Intellectual Ventures, says that's getting easier because every year more patents are issued than the year before. According to a Yale study, it's 100 software patents a day.
汤姆·尤因，那位追踪高智发明的律师说，这变得更容易了，因为每年签发的专利比前一年更多。根据耶鲁大学的一项研究，每天有100项软件专利。
It took 121 years for us to get the first 1 million patents. Now it takes more or less six years to get another million patents.
我们花了121年才获得前100万项专利。现在差不多只需六年就能再获得100万项。
And the more patents are issued, the less careful the patent office seems to be. According to a study by the Organization of Economic Cooperation and Development, quote, "The rush to protect even minor improvements in products or services is overburdening patent offices. This slows the time to market for true innovations and reduces the potential for breakthrough inventions."
而且签发的专利越多，专利局看起来就越不谨慎。根据经济合作与发展组织的一项研究，“竞相保护产品或服务中哪怕是微小的改进，都在使专利局不堪重负。这减缓了真正创新的上市时间，并减少了突破性发明的潜力。”
Case in point--
案例说明——
About three years ago this time of the year, my father passed away from a heart attack.
大约三年前的这个时候，我的父亲因心脏病去世了。
Not long ago, I was at a meeting in San Francisco put on by the Electronic Frontier Foundation, an advocacy group that's been critical of the patent system. It was an open meeting. And this guy you hear talking, Nick Desaulniers, had decided on the spur of the moment to drop in. And after hearing a couple of other people tell their stories, he got up to tell his.
不久前，我在旧金山参加了一个由电子前沿基金会举办的会议，这是一个批评专利制度的倡导组织。那是一个公开会议。你听到说话的这个人，尼克·德索尼尔斯，临时决定过来看看。在听了其他人讲故事后，他起身讲述了他的。
He's an engineer. And his father's death had spurred him to invent a low-cost heart monitor, which he believed might have saved his dad's life. He developed a prototype in a graduate school class. And he'd started dreaming a bit.
他是一名工程师。他父亲的去世促使他发明了一种低成本心脏监护仪，他相信这本可能救他父亲一命。他在研究生班开发了一个原型。他开始做梦了。
You know, I got really excited about it. And I was thinking, maybe I can make a business out of this. My grandfather started his own business.
你知道，我对此真的很兴奋。我想，也许我可以从中创办一家企业。我祖父创办了自己的企业。
My father made his own business. I need to make my own business someday. So this was something I was really thinking, like, hey, I can make a business out of this.
我父亲创办了自己的企业。总有一天我也要创办自己的企业。所以我真的很想，嘿，我可以从中创办一家企业。
But then he started a patent search to see if anyone else had come up with something resembling his idea already.
但随后他开始进行专利搜索，看看是否已经有人想出了类似他的想法。
I was horrified at how generic some of the patents were-- "a system for remotely monitoring physiological signals." What the hell does that mean? There are so many ways, so many variables.
对于一些专利有多通用，我感到恐惧——“一种远程监视生理信号的系统”。那到底是什么意思？有那么多方式，那么多变量。
How are you getting the data from point A to point B? There are so many ways to do that. And this patent, it covers-- I guess it covers them all.
你是怎么把数据从A点传到B点的？有那么多方法。而这个专利，我想它涵盖了它们全部。
And seeing some of the numbers that these companies are going back and forth suing each other for, I'm terrified to create a business because of the patent system. I'm horrified. And I'm scared.
看到这些公司为了起诉对方而反复提到的数字，因为专利制度，我害怕创办企业。我感到恐惧。我害怕。
And I'm not going to create a business because of it. So however many jobs I could have created or however many lives I could have saved, that's it.
我不会因为这个而创办企业。所以无论我本可以创造多少工作岗位或挽救多少生命，都没了。
Thanks.
谢谢。
And that is the current state of things. Something as dry as the US patent system can move somebody to tears.
这就是现状。像美国专利制度这样枯燥的东西可以让人潸然泪下。
Since our last broadcast, we've gotten used to front-page stories about huge tech companies in multimillion dollar battles over patents. But what hasn't been making the front page as often-- patent cases spreading to the rest of us. Over the last couple of years, there have been numerous stories about small businesses-- individuals even-- getting hit with patent infringement lawsuits.
自我们上次广播以来，我们已经习惯了关于大型科技公司在专利上进行数百万美元争夺战的头条新闻。但没那么经常上头条的是——专利案件蔓延到我们其他人身上。过去几年里，有无数关于小企业——甚至个人——遭受专利侵权诉讼的故事。
A group called Innovatio has been going around suing coffee shops and grocery stores for violating its patent on providing Wi-Fi in a public space. They say they own that idea. And if your coffee shop is providing Wi-Fi, you owe them money. They say they've made a strategic and business judgment not go after people using Wi-Fi in their own homes, quote, "at this stage." Another company called Boadin Technologies, LLC, has sued a bunch of media organizations, saying that one of its patents is infringed every time a word or phrase on your computer autocompletes.
一个叫Innovatio的组织一直在起诉咖啡店和杂货店，称它们违反了其在公共场所提供Wi-Fi的专利。他们说他们拥有那个想法。如果你的咖啡店提供Wi-Fi，你就欠他们钱。他们说他们做出了战略和商业判断，暂时“现阶段”不去追究在自己家里使用Wi-Fi的人。另一家名为Boadin Technologies, LLC的公司起诉了一堆媒体机构，称其一项专利在每次你的电脑自动完成一个单词或短语时就受到侵权。
And a company in Vermont called MPHJ Technology has sent licensing letters to hundreds of businesses in Vermont, saying, any time an employee scans something to be emailed, that employee is infringing on MPHJ's patent. They say they own the idea of scanning a document and then emailing it. They're asking for around $1,000 per employee in damages. One of the companies they've approached is a nonprofit serving disabled people.
而佛蒙特州一家名为MPHJ Technology的公司向佛蒙特州的数百家企业发送了许可信，称任何时候员工扫描东西并通过电子邮件发送时，该员工就在侵犯MPHJ的专利。他们说他们拥有扫描文件然后通过电子邮件发送这个想法。他们要求每位员工赔偿约1000美元。他们接触过的公司之一是一家为残疾人服务的非营利组织。
There are five bills in Congress co-sponsored by Republicans and Democrats aimed at overhauling the patent system. This is still in the very early stages. And of course, it's hard to get any bill passed ever. But this issue has attracted one thing you need to get action in Washington, DC-- powerful people in business interests who want change-- the tech industry, the supermarket industry, the Consumer Electronics Association, Google, and of course, the mighty podcast lobby.
国会有五项由共和党和民主党共同发起的法案，旨在全面改革专利制度。这仍处于非常初期的阶段。当然，要通过任何法案都很难。但这个问题已经吸引了你在华盛顿特区采取行动所需的一样东西——在商业利益上有权势的人，他们想要改变——科技行业、超市行业、消费电子协会、谷歌，当然还有强大的播客游说团体。
That's one difference between now and when we first reported on this story two years ago. Now when we talk to people who are trying to reform the system, they seem hopeful.
这是我们两年前首次报道这个故事时与现在的一个区别。现在当我们与那些试图改革制度的人交谈时，他们看起来很有希望。
Laura Sydell and Alex Blumberg. This story was a co-production with NPR News. Planet Money, which Alex co-founded, is also a co-production of our program and NPR News. Its website and free podcast is at npr.org/money.
劳拉·赛德尔和亚历克斯·布隆伯格。这个故事是与NPR新闻联合制作的。亚历克斯共同创立的《Planet Money》也是我们节目与NPR新闻的联合制作。其网站和免费播客地址是npr.org/money。
[MUSIC - "NO IDEA'S ORIGINAL" BY NAS]
[音乐 - NAS的《NO IDEA'S ORIGINAL》]
Well, our program was produced today by our senior producer, Julie Snyder, Alex Blumberg, and me with Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Production help from Phia Bennin; Seth Lind, our operations director; Emily Condon, our production manager; Elise Bergerson, our administrative assistant. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddes. Research by Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Special thanks today to Leslie Ogrodnick, Krish Gupta, and Uri Berliner.
嗯，我们的节目今天由高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德、亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我制作，还有本·卡尔霍恩、萨拉·科尼格、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。制作帮助来自菲亚·贝宁；赛斯·林德，我们的运营总监；艾米丽·康顿，我们的制作经理；伊莉斯·伯格森，我们的行政助理。音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·盖德斯。研究由米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔完成。今天特别感谢莱斯利·奥格罗德尼克、克里什·古普塔和尤里·伯林纳。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who I just caught eating food I had in the fridge, even though I had written clearly on the bag, "Ira's lunch."
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由美国公共广播国际公司发行。我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，我刚刚抓到他在吃我放在冰箱里的食物，尽管我在袋子上清楚地写着“艾拉的午餐”。
As far as the apostrophe S, I'm still not clear if you're trying to derive a specific meaning with respect to the apostrophe S.
至于撇号S，我仍然不清楚你是否想根据撇号S衍生出特定的含义。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI-- Public Radio International.
PRI——美国公共广播国际公司。